while is it is an honor to appear before
you today I want to make clear that I
did not seek this opportunity to testify
today since you determined that I may
have something of value to these
proceedings and issued a subpoena it is
my obligation to appear and to tell you
what I know
indeed as secretary Pompeo has stated I
hope everyone who testifies we'll do so
truthfully and accurately what when they
do the oversight role will have been
performed and I think America will come
to see what took place here that is my
only goal to testify truthfully and
accurately to enable you to perform that
role also on June 28th while President
Trump was still not moving forward on a
meeting beginning in March 2019 the
situation at the Embassy and in Ukraine
changed dramatically
specifically the three priorities of
security economy and justice and our
support for Ukrainian democratic
resistance to Russian aggression became
overshadowed by a political agenda
promoted by former New York New York
City Mayor Rudy Giuliani and a cadre of
officials operating with a direct
channel to the White House policy
community of it's important
NSC counterparts confirms us following
president-elect solinsky's victory our
attention in the embassy focused on
getting to know the incoming zalenski
administration and on preparations for
the inauguration scheduled for May 20th
the same day that ambassador Jovanovic
departed post permanently it was cool it
quickly became clear that the White
House was not prepared to show the level
of support for the Zielinski
administration that we had originally
anticipated we became concerned that
even if a meeting between presidents
Trump and szalinski could occur it would
not go well and I discussed with embassy
colleagues whether we should stop
seeking a meeting all together while the
White House visit was critical to this
alinsky administration a visit that
failed to send a clear and strong signal
of support likely would be worse for
president zalenski the no visit at all
given the history of US security
assistance to Ukraine and the bipartisan
record by partisan recognition of its
importance I was shocked when on July
18th and office of management and budget
staff member surprisingly announced the
hold on Ukraine's security assistance
the announcement came toward the end of
a nearly two hour national security
council secure video conference call
which I participated in from the embassy
conference room the officials said that
the order had come from the president it
had been conveyed to OMB by mr. Mulvaney
with no further explanation on July 25th
president Trump made a congratulatory
phone call to president zalenski after
his party won a commanding majority in
Ukraine's parliamentary election
contrary to standard procedure the
embassy received no readout of that call
and I was unaware of what was discussed
until the transcript was released on
September 25th upon reading the
transcript I was deeply disappointed to
see that the president raised none of
what I understood to be our interagency
agreed-upon foreign policy priorities in
Ukraine and instead raised the Biden
barrese my investigation and referred to
the theory about CrowdStrike
and it's supposed connection to Ukraine
in the 2016 election competitors in the
world we have no better friends than
Ukraine during the lunch Ambassador
Sandlin said that he was going to call
president Trump to give him an update
master silen placed a call on his mobile
phone
I heard him announce himself several
times along the lines of Gordon's song
and holding for the president it
appeared that he was being transferred
through several layers of switchboards
and assistance and I then noticed
ambassador soglin's demeanor changed and
understood that he had been connected to
president Trump I then heard president
Trump ask so he's going to do the
investigation
ambassador Soglin replied that he's
going to do it
adding the president szalinski will do
anything you asked him to do even though
I did not take notes of these statements
I have a clear recollection that these
statements were made I believe that my
colleagues who are sitting at the table
also knew that ambassador
was speaking with the president direct
role in Ukrainian diplomacy on April
25th
Evon I then took the opportunity to ask
ambassador Soglin for his candid
impression of the president's views on
Ukraine in particular I asked ambassador
Soglin if it was true that the president
did not give a expletive about Ukraine
ambassador song that agreed that the
president did not give an expletive
about Ukraine
I asked why not an ambassador songless
stated that the president only cares
about big stuff I noted there was big
stuff going on in Ukraine like a war
with Russia an ambassador Soglin replied
that he meant big stuff that benefits
the president like the Biden
investigation that mr. Giuliani was
pushing him gets to play the racism card
by this point however my clear
impression was that the security
assistance hold was likely intended by
the president either as an expression of
dissatisfaction with Ukrainians who had
not yet agreed to the Purisima Biden
investigation or as an effort to
increase the pressure on them to do so
as the impeachment inquiry has
progressed I followed press reports and
reviewed the statements of ambassador's
tailor and in yovanovich based on my
experiences in Ukraine my recollection
is generally consistent with their
testimony and I believe that the
relevant facts were therefore being laid
out for the American people however in
the last couple weeks I read press
reports expressing for the first time
that certain senior officials may have
been acting without the president's
knowledge or freelancing in their
dealings with Ukraine at the same time
read reports noting the lack of
first-hand evidence in the investigation
and suggesting that the only evidence
being elicited the hearings was hearsay
I came to realize that I had first-hand
knowledge regarding certain events on
July 26 that had not otherwise been
reported and that those events
potentially bore on the question of
whether the President did in fact have
knowledge that those senior officials
were using the levers of diplomatic
power to influence the new Ukrainian
President to announce the opening of a
criminal investigation against president
Trump's political opponent remain to
this inquiry while I'm a political
counselor at the Embassy it is at that
point that I made the observation to
ambassador Taylor that the incident I
witnessed on July 26th had acquired
greater significance which is what he
reported in his testimony last week and
is what led to the subpoena for me to
appear here today in conclusion I'd like
to take a moment to turn this year's
Revolution at the ballot box underscores
the despite its imperfections Ukraine is
a genuine and vibrant democracy and an
example to other post-soviet countries
and beyond from Moscow to Hong Kong how
we respond to this historic opportunity
will set the trajectory of our
relationship with Ukraine and will
define our willingness to defend our
bedrock international principles and our
leadership role in the world
you